joining us now vice president Mike Pence
mr. vice president thanks for the time
yeah thank you brother
you're up here obviously shepherding if
you will the new nominee for the US
Supreme Court it's all about counting
heads in the Senate tonight as you sit
here how do you feel about this
potential vote well I think we feel very
encouraged at the early response not
just here at the United States Capitol
but really all across the country to
judge Brett Kavanaugh to his personal
story to his his incredible record 12
years on the District of Columbia Court
of Appeals he had fully 12 different
opinions that were adopted by the United
States Supreme Court he is someone that
has the character the background the
career and the record that that gave
President Trump the confidence to know
that when he appointed judge Kavanagh to
the Supreme Court that he would be like
Neal Gorsuch like Justice Scalia he
would be another constitutional
conservative who would faithfully
interpret the Constitution as written I
want to talk about his record in the
substance and what's being said about it
by the left but I want to talk quickly
about process you have senator Murkowski
saying there's a long record here and we
need to slow down and they need to take
their time looking at it senator
Grassley says this all needs to be sped
up and move this process along and it
shouldn't drag out who's right there
well I'm meeting tonight with Senator
Grassley and senator Feinstein to talk
about the Judiciary Committee's process
and the role and look what the
administration is going to work very
closely with members of the committee
and members of the Senate to make judge
Kavanaugh available to make the
information available that they need to
do their important constitutional role
but I but I have to tell you Brett as
you look at this good man as you look at
a lifetime of service in a variety of
different roles and you look at that
record 300 decisions that he made on the
District of Columbia Court of Appeals
we have every confidence that as members
of the Senate come to know and
appreciate judge Cavanaugh as the
American people come to know and
appreciate this principle jurist that
we'll see him confirm you know there's a
huge pushback from the left
Gillibrand Freedom this just must not
become the next justice on the Supreme
Court
what President Trump was looking for was
a judge with the background the
temperament and the experience who we
would be confident would faithfully
interpret the Constitution as written
the president wanted to put someone on
the bench who would not legislate from
the bench who would not as has been to
much of the case in the last generation
or more where we've had members of our
federal judiciary who literally have
been making policy and making law from
the bench president looked looked at
this judge and all of the candidates for
this opening through that prism and that
was the basis of this decision here's
the other argument sent a minority
leader today about this choice Senator
McConnell told the president that there
were other nominees who could have been
for affirmed more easily why did the
president stick with Kavanagh because
he's worried
[Applause]
that mr. Muller will go to the court and
ask that the president be subpoenaed and
asked to do other things necessary to
move the investigation forward and
president Trump knows that Cavanaugh
will be a barrier to preventing that
investigation from going there this
decision has anything to do with the
Muller investigation I I don't believe
it did in any way what what the
president focused on was a judicial
philosophy what he focused on was a body
of work by Judge Cavanaugh and we
examined other candidates who were
finalists for this position to see if we
could end that body of work determined
that this was a judge who would would
faithfully uphold and interpret the
Constitution as written it it really was
the lodestar in the course of all of
this now look make no mistake about it
the judge Cavanaugh is a is a he's a
he's a conservative jurist he's a
principled conservative in the tradition
of Justice Scalia when you look at cases
that he's ruled on on limited government
on federalism on the Second Amendment on
religious liberty in one case after
another you see a consistent judicial
philosophy come forward we're obviously
looking at all of the reaction and when
this vote will come together but there
are other things happening namely the
meeting in NATO the president heading
overseas and then the summit with
Vladimir Putin the present was asked
whether Vladimir's a foe or a friend
tipless I really can't say right now as
far as I'm concerned
competitor to competitor I think that
getting along with Russia getting along
with China getting along with others
it's a good thing not a bad thing I've
said that many times I have the UK which
is in somewhat turmoil and a half foot
thankfully Putin may be the easiest of
them all who would think what would
think so we're putting a friend or foe
the president made it clear that we have
competing interests with Russia but it
doesn't change the fact whether it be
Syria where Russia's involved militarily
on behalf of the Assad regime where our
military forces have bravely been in the
process of destroying Isis at its source
that we need to find a way to work in
common cause for a long-term solution in
Syria we have the we have the issues in
Ukraine other issues that are exist
between our countries and as president
Trump has said many times he always
believes in talking he believes in
sitting down with leaders in determining
whether there's a way that we can make
progress in the relationship and I think
he goes into this summit very much in
that spirit but in the wake of what
happened in North Korea and what we're
seeing so far is there a skepticism
about this you know considering what you
saw from secretary Pompeo s visit there
well I think President Trump believes in
engagement but he's someone who's is a
realist about the world now with regard
to North Korea I will tell you that
pronouncements following the Secretary
of State's a recent visit by some in the
foreign ministry of North Korea
notwithstanding president Trump still
believes that the agreement that was
reached in Singapore where North Korea
agreed to complete denuclearization
represents a commitment that we we can
make progress on them we're going to
continue to work through that we're not
going to be sidelines or
tract and you heard the Secretary of
State speak about the progress in the
midst of other challenges that we have
but look we we have great challenges
around the world and what what the
American people can be confident of is
the president I serve with every day
he's always going to put America first
it's one of the reasons why this
president signed the largest increase in
military spending since the days of
Ronald Reagan 700 billion dollars in
military spending I mean the the
commitment this president has made to
call on our allies at NATO to live up to
their commitment to our common defense
is all about making sure that both the
United States is secure that the
Alliance of the West is strong and from
that strong position will and will
engage leaders on the Korean Peninsula
the Asian Pacific in Russia and
elsewhere around the world but it will
be seeking peace through strength
the last thing mr. vice president last
time I talked to you in this very room
actually an interview I asked you about
former national security adviser Mike
Flint I think it is a it is an
affirmation of the president's decision
to ask general Flynn to resign today
he's in court and in dealing with the
possible sentence for lying to the FBI
Jim Comey and Andrew McCabe both told
Congress that the interviewing agents
they didn't believe in their testimony
saw any signs of deception is it
possible that Flynn was confused when he
talked to you do you think that all went
down the right way as you look back at
it now I think the president made the
right decision to dismiss the general
Flynn in the wake of those events and as
I said we're we're fully cooperating
with the Special Counsel to make sure
that they have all the information that
we have relative and to those issues but
whether but I can assure the American
people is as all of that goes on the
progress that we're making making our
country more secure and strong
pterri investments making our border
more secure dealing with the crisis on
our southern border rolling back
regulations and cutting taxes so that we
have a tremendous economic growth are
all a result of the determined
leadership of President Donald Trump in
our entire team to keep our promises to
the American people and this nomination
of Judge Brett Kavanaugh to the Supreme
Court of the United States is just the
latest installment of what whatever else
might be going on whatever else might be
a focus of people in the media this
president is going to always get up
every day just as we all do and stay
focused on a stronger more prosperous
more secure America and that's just what
we're accomplishing as vice president we
appreciate the time thank you breath